you've got a sports drink out recovery
tell me about recovery can this help me
marshawn i need help is recovery the
thing
let's get it you zoom in on that huh
yeah i want to get i want to give this
the real treatment this is recovery tell
me
could this help me because you know me
marshawn i am a
a top physical specimen i push myself
100 all the time recovery
could this help me you damn right it
could help you
and i mean not just not just not just
from uh
not just from a long workout i mean it
can help you from a
long night of drinking or a long night
of
extra curricular activity
so whatever you feel you need some
recovery from i mean you know
i like being the jack of all trades and
i think with that juice you feel me that
recovery drink
i think you know it gives you a little
benefit to recovering from a lot of
yeah so i mean you know you could you
could get out and do a bus
down or you could bust down
or you feel me you could drink on
something
and you take a little recovery the next
morning and you be straight
ready to do it all over again yeah i
mean i both bust down and sometimes i
bust them
down and this is what i need i need
recovery you know
this is what i'm talking what do i do i
open it right here all the good
nutrients and
and uh right there
you twist it and it gets blasted in yeah
look at that look at that well you look
recovered
i look so recovered i feel fantastic
you look like you ready to do something
guess what marshawn stuff's happening
down here that hasn't happened
in five years five
years so now that's
see now that's not the buzz down now
that's the bust down
now i'm ready to bust him down
[Laughter]
marshawn i'm going to say this first of
all
you can now play as marshawn check this
out you can play as marshawn in predator
hunting grounds on playstation and pc
and this is great a portion of all sales
of marshawn's recovery immunity drink
will be donated to his fam first
family foundation